oh boys i have something very special
planned today okay they said it wouldn't
happen
the comments said it couldn't be done
but i finally did it i wrote
a powerpoint presentation oh for all you
actually did it you actually did 20
weeks ago was that this was like a week
like
10 years like episode like nine months
and i was like what just that was just
like
you know when you say something offhand
and then it was an offhand comment
yeah it was an offhand comment and then
the community and the reddit would just
like never let you forget that you said
that one thing
to explain what ghana's talking about i
don't know which episode it was play the
flashback mood on what i gotta do is i
gotta
some episode i need to bring a
presentation of all the different ways
people have tried to hit on
like i gotta please it's like it's a
powerpoint presentation
the most interesting ways it's happening
so i thought i made a little
presentation
with a fun little some fun images to
explain all the different ways that you
can be
so i guess i should pull the laptop up
so are you gonna are you about to break
down the 93 percent
right here 93 it's not the 93 anymore
it's like 50 50. this is how you can
also be the 93
sign up first month is a hundred dollars
i want to preface this is not my laptop
because it has stickers on it so it's
yeah it's my beautiful laptop
youtube a guide to being hit on all the
way oh my god
wow this is bringing me back to like
high school dude you're you're
okay you've just done a possible
presentation i did i did so
is this your ted talk dude this is my
ted talk ted didn't invite me so i
thought
okay before we start how much effort did
you put into this not that much
so this is like okay so basically i
these are all true things that have
happened at one point or another um
and i i didn't write all the whole
details out so basically they're more
prompt
to for my memory to be like oh yeah this
is what happened all right let me
explain it's like a real ted talk
i guess so yeah this isn't like the high
school i'm reading off the powerpoint
presentation there's literally like two
sentences just to remind me wow oh it's
this story okay
um but yeah i do i do want to preface
before we begin um
i'm not trying to make out that i'm some
kind of like [ __ ] sex
god that can no one can resi it's
literally just
when you have x amount of subscribers
obviously there's going to be two people
out there that are stupid enough to
think that i'm attractive and try and
hit on me
right okay you're being very humble
there i do not
i am like ex hot or whatever this just
happens with the job i think
people don't try it with you because you
know you guys are basically married all
right
not to each other of course
why are you laughing melee bailey's like
i love the gay talk
all right so like so tell me more about
how they married what do you expect to
see on this list
uh excited god just i don't know
basically i'm just looking forward to
this presentation just being a massive
excuse to say i'm not a fuckboy bar
yeah no no no you know you know
obviously didn't reciprocate you know
but because most of these are strange
yeah i've also accompanied
uh i just downloaded a bunch of stock
images i didn't pay i didn't i didn't
pay for the license i shouldn't say that
but i just downloaded the bunch still
thank you thank you getty images yes so
that could just accompany it just for
fun
we have the classic to start with what
is that
so this is as i've said a text to my
personal number okay what how did they
get your personal number
that's what i want to know god i don't
know so this happened about
i think four or five months into my
youtube
career if you will yeah i thought great
i haven't leaked anything
2015. yeah i was wondering how the [ __ ]
someone had done this yeah yeah um so it
turned out at the time
i had an iphone and the email that i
listed
was actually like my email linked to my
iphone account
right and someone had just connected the
dots of like oh i should put with this
email on my iphone
text connor don't use iphone anymore oh
that's how because they didn't
they did they did the imessage thing
right right so i deleted that email
so yeah it doesn't exist immediately
yeah because i was like [ __ ] this but at
the time it was
very creepy to wake up to a text from an
american number being like
hi is this connor by the way it's not
exactly being hit on but
stopped it before it could get there all
right yeah that's the first one i think
it's a stock image
i've actually had something similar
happen to me admire
what is that stock image i don't know
these are all strange stock images so
she's just saying no to
the potato but like yeah i i've had
something
i've had similar things happen to me
where i'm not going to name what
a messaging app or whatever it was on
but uh like i've realized that
you could find my username obviously
pretty easily through this messaging app
and i i would get like people adding me
and just messaging me randomly on it
and then it and that that that was that
was a humble experience to realize oh
okay i can't just yeah
yeah i [ __ ] up i can't use this email
for everything now
all right the classy the fan mail the
actual handwritten
letter oh oh like physical yeah okay is
this essentially your p.o box let's just
send to my p.o box okay
i was about to ask how they found your
address yeah po box you know
had a you know had a few letters that
were asking if i was you know
because they would know what conventions
i'm going to and then they would say hey
is it possible that maybe we could you
know go on a date or something
and obviously you know i never got that
even when i was single
no no no what uh maybe the time have
changed yeah
but youtubers weren't cool back then you
know right this is like two
three years ago this used to happen it
didn't happen that often but like people
would attach their numbers
and like and they'd never and then they
would have that i mean
by the time when i first started really
blowing up on the anime community i was
already
pretty much dating city oh yeah and you
know if if
like sydney makes a let's see she marks
the territory
she wards off the laser eyes the
predators also
out of the stock image this one
what is happening
and then this one is the modern the fan
email obviously you get emails okay yeah
yeah um and then this is the the stonk
image because this is
me putting the emails in the trash uh
when you send them to me
this is all the fan mails we get for
trash tanks
all pretty standard so far for youtubers
yeah yeah yeah okay okay next we have uh
the the extra classy i would have a i
used to do patreon fan letters
where you could pay to be pen pals with
me okay that sounds like
that doesn't sound like a nightmare is
about to happen that when i made that i
didn't think it was gonna so it's not on
there anymore but i used to i used to
think that it was like oh this is such a
cool way to connect with me
yeah and i didn't realize about like the
logistics yeah yeah because you never do
with patreon you never think about the
logistics until you realize
oh i have to do this every month oh yeah
basically i agreed to write like 20
letters
a month which uh i'm not good at writing
either and i don't like writing yeah so
writing one
one letter for me takes like 30 minutes
i've seen it i've seen your hands
writing so it's not
writing so much so it was just painful
and
it was really frustrating as well sorry
i'll go on to how to get hit after but
it was frustrating as well because like
people would join patreon for like one
month and leave so i would send out a
letter
that would just be like hi how are you
nice to meet you tell me about yourself
and then not get a response but i'd have
to write
but i'd have to write like seven of
those letters a month yeah every month
and i was like doing them all by hand
how how long was the letter itself uh
like a page or two jeez
geez that's a long for how much a month
i think it was on like the 40
tier but that was included with the
voicemail so like how much how much
would uh
let's let's break this down cost to
effort-wise how much would it take you
too long write a letter not long
i mean i guess if they paid 40 dollars
for 30 minutes worth of work but
i always get distracted and i couldn't
focus because i just didn't want to be
doing it yeah
right so it was awful but yeah i had i
had someone as well same same with the
fan letter who was like
um they like it was this really weird
situation where i'm not really sure what
happened because i was just being like
ah yeah cool i like pokemon too
i like these things because i would try
and be honest and try and make a
friendship with them
yeah and then they were like they
replied one time being like oh
yeah so i told my my co-workers at work
that i have a boyfriend and i said it
was you
and i was like and then they asked like
is that okay and i was like
uh sure i don't give a [ __ ] like i'm not
gonna go wrong i'm not gonna go around
saying that
you can say that like she
she brings up the sea dog va youtubers
that's amazing
she's like hey you wanna see my
boyfriend that's my boy right look at
that guy
sebastian he's he's his name's sebastian
i'm just thinking i'm like is that a
brag because if they pull up my videos
half of them is
either gonna be me reading bl or me uh
in the cosplay yeah and i think i think
they were from like midwest somewhere
it's a very conservative state so i
couldn't imagine they would take too
kindly to
me being like naked in my room basically
going ah you know like
so yeah that was interesting that was
fun um also it's a boyfriend that never
like [ __ ] responds to like
messages or anything it's a boyfriend
there's a one-way boy it's a boyfriend
that yeah that replies uh
once a month via mail yeah